this is Elon musk's boring company the
company's found a game to rid the world
of congestion by building tunnels that
could autonomously rapidly shuttle cars
from A to B I think finally finally
finally there's something that I think
could solved goddamn traffic problem or
at least that was the original idea but
fast forward to today and congestion is
still very much a thing and the
company's idea of traffic busting
tunnels is not quite there yet
so as always we're going to look at
where the boring company is now where it
wants to be and then examine what it
needs to do to get there but let's start
with where it wants to be
the idea for the boring company seemed
to start when musk tweeted traffic is
driving me nuts I'm going to build a
tunnel boring machine and just start
digging fast forward a few months and
musk launched the company along with a
vision for how these tunnels would
hypothetically eliminate traffic you
drive your vehicle onto a platform at
street level and then are lowered into a
network of tunnels where the platform
and your vehicle are whisked along at
speeds of between 120 and 150 miles an
hour at the end of The Journey you pop
back out at street level and drive off
there's no real limit to how many levels
of tunnel you can have is that you can
go much further deep than you can go up
the company soon followed up with some
ideas for where this Tech could be
deployed like a 35 mile tunnel from
downtown DC to downtown Baltimore which
would carry passengers at least 30 feet
underground and take approximately 15
minutes there were also sketches for
routes across LA and connecting
locations like downtown Chicago with
Chicago O'Hare Airport part of the
attraction of the company was that the
quotes to deploy its technology were
often magnitudes of millions cheaper
than other Transportation options like
like rail so what has the boring company
achieved so far well in early 2022 the
company was valued at some 5.7 billion
dollars but when it comes to physical
infrastructure the company has little to
show for it outside of a handful of
short tunnels thanks for coming to uh
this hole in the ground born completed a
few short tunnels on its properties in
Hawthorne California and near Austin
Texas for r d purposes and then there's
the 1.7 Mile Las Vegas Convention Center
Loop which connects different Halls of
the convention center the boring company
says that the loop at one point
transported around 26 000 passengers per
day and has an average ride time of less
than two minutes but most of those
initially proposed projects like that
Baltimore DC Loop have been removed from
the boring company's website when my
colleagues Ted Mann and Julie bikowitz
reported on this they found the company
often pulled out when confronted with
the realities of building public
infrastructure and what they do have is
quite a long way off from that original
concept instead of allowing any vehicle
to drive up and then autonomously be
carried Along on a platform you have to
instead get in the back of a show for
Tesla and they're not autonomous Teslas
either initially the ride was guided
Along by guide Wheels but that led to
issues with ride Comfort I do warn you
it's going to be a slightly bumpy ride
it's a little rough around the edges so
now the guide Wheels have gone too then
there's speed while musk has said
multiple times that Riders will be
rocketed along at speeds in excess of
100 miles an hour for passengers it's
never quite lived up to that probably in
your trophy you maybe go 40 50 miles an
hour the Teslas in the Vegas loot tend
to go around 30 miles an hour that's
about the same speed as well a car on a
normal road if that road were clear and
it's left musk's tunnels as essentially
just that another road only underground
and only driven on by chauffeured Teslas
so what would it take for the boring
companies tunnels to actually reduce
traffic up for starters they need to
start allowing more different types of
private vehicles to travel down them and
not just show for Teslas the company
would also be closer to alleviating
traffic if the vehicles or the platforms
carrying them could be autonomous as it
would mean they'd be able to travel
faster and closer together and the
boring company would need to deploy its
Loop in more places and over greater
distances Clark County and Las Vegas
city government councils recently
approved 34 miles of boring company
tunnels which the boring company will
finance it's unclear if that project
will materialize but even if all of this
happens there's still a risk of
something called induced demand see if a
freeway gets congested you can decongest
it by adding another Lane but it only
works for a short while as the traffic
starts flowing freely again the road
becomes more popular and before you know
it more congestion until the boring
company finds a way to take cars off the
street and efficiently get them from A
to B in their tunnels faster than on
roads all they're doing is just adding
another Lane to a highway the company
didn't respond to my request for comment
so to kill congestion months and for all
the boring company will need to actually
build tunnels and not walk away from
proposals then dramatically expand that
Network to make it useful open the
tunnels up to a wider range of vehicles
and find a way to autonomously or
efficiently move vehicles through its
tunnel network if the company does that
then maybe they could finally sort
goddamn traffic problem but until then
I'd make sure you have some good
playlists loaded in your car as traffic
could be around for some years to come
[Music]